[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to the very
first episode of ask
google cloud the show where you get to
ask google cloud experts your
burning questions like are dogs or cats
better
i'm just kidding that's going to be way
too controversial so we're just going to
stick to
cloud topics i'm stephanie wong a google
cloud developer advocate
and today i'm joined by martin omander
developer advocate for google cloud
serverless and james ward also developer
advocate also focused on serverless
so today we're going to be answering
questions submitted by you
our amazing and dynamic google cloud
youtube audience
we're always looking out for your
questions about google cloud products so
be sure to leave any questions you might
have in the comments of our videos
using the hashtag askgooglecloud
we actually read them yeah i know what a
concept right
and if you also have other questions
that come up as you're watching today
please type them in the live chat and we
will do our best to try and get to them
all
we'll be hosting ask google cloud
segments throughout the year so be sure
to subscribe to the channel
to get notified every time a new episode
comes out
with that said let's go ahead and get
started with today's topic
all things serverless so our first
question
comes from aja deep sorry if i butcher
names what workloads work well for
serverless i think this might be the
million dollar question of today
so uh martin why don't we go ahead and
start with you
yeah uh we we do a lot of surveys with
developers and ask them what they use
serverless for
and one of the top use cases that always
comes in in is apis
either you have an api that you build
between your system and another system
or you have an api that sits between
your backend and your mobile client
or your backend and your web client and
serverless is great for that because
we're talking about api calls that's
like a quick little thing that needs to
run
and load can vary a lot over time as
well so serverless really shines for
that
amazing explanation yeah yeah anything
with really uh
anything with like real dynamic load
where it's constantly changing
the the traffic so if it's fluctuating
based on time of day
or maybe you need to support a super
bowl ad
something of that scale the ability to
scale from zero
all of a sudden to millions of uh people
using a particular service that's uh
that's where serverless is great it's
just that
huge dynamic uh fluctuating yeah it
sounds like
data processing is another great one it
sounds like it can vary from small
workloads to large so
is there a size differential or is there
something that it's more particularly
suited towards in terms of workload
sides or api calls
i think it actually it works really well
for
small workloads when you have something
every now and then that needs to run
then you don't have to pay for the
server 24 7
only when it's executing but also good
for work large workloads like
like you were saying james here the
super bowl ad comes on or
black friday rolls around and it's a big
variation in in traffic uh when it's
large
uh large traffic so i think it's
actually good for both
awesome okay so we have a lot of
questions so our second question comes
from
jayesh who asks how are serverless
architectures
better and i kind of feel like this
might be one of those it depends answers
but
let's go ahead and go to you james
sure yeah so i think to talk about this
one of the useful things to focus on
is cloud native architectures and when
you build for cloud native
or it could also be called 12-factor
architectures
when you build for these things that can
dynamically scale can go from zero to as
many
backing servers as you need then your
architect
needs to support that so it needs to be
able to
handle that up and down that fluctuation
and uh there's certain architectural
things that make this easier
so for instance if you don't have any
state in your
actual application or service that's one
thing that allows you to easily scale up
and down you move that state back to a
database back to an
external cache that sort of thing and so
12 factor and cloud native are going to
really be the thing that enables you to
embrace serverless
and and that's great whether you're on
kubernetes or on cloud run
or really any serverless platform and
and i think i'm working with a
large retailer right now and they're
using serverless because
they a large retailer but small team
they can't afford to pay you know have
lots and lots of ops people
monitoring servers and they want to
build stuff and and enable more services
uh not sit around and monitor services
so that they've gone serverless for that
reason
to make their own team more efficient
yeah and i think this is a good segue
into our next question who's from
man yun who asks what's the difference
between
serverless and cloud native i think we
hear both of these terms
a lot and i don't know if they're
interchangeable but it sounds like
they're related
um james what do you think yeah they're
definitely related so
serverless i look at serverless more of
as martin was saying the
like operational model of cloud native
applications
you certainly can do cloud native
without serverless without going full
server listen without having that
dynamic scaling and the managed platform
but if you're cloud native then it's
going to make it a lot easier for you to
also be serverless
and so um so yes if you're if you're
starting with
non-cloud native first focus on being
cloud native
and then that will enable you to also be
serverless for the operational aspects
to that
yeah and here's a personal question um
you're talking about moving
state outside of the application logic
how difficult is
it in your opinion for companies who may
have a monolithic app or legacy
applications to move to more of a cloud
native or serverless model
it's it can definitely be challenging
because we
traditionally have architected
applications to be these
uh what we call um we want to treat them
as
as uh what is it not cattle uh
cat or no we wanna treat them as cattle
not um pets
is the the terminology that we've heard
used and it's kind of a mean way to talk
about cattle because
you know we love cows but the idea is
that
with with your pets you you you really
love your pet dearly and you don't ever
want that pet to go away
um and so with our traditional
architectures we would make sure that
that the server should never go down you
try to keep that thing running
forever and if it goes down you have an
outage whereas in cloud native
we're actually architecting to support
the ability to fail
because we know that at the scale and at
the
uh when we move our architecture to uh
to
huge data centers that are managing
millions of machines
that things may break uh at that scale
and so we have to
we have to architect for that and so
that's one of the key things about cloud
native is
moving that state out and so it can be a
huge challenge
to going cloud native and going
serverless
just things like the file system in
serverless and cloud native you
typically
don't write files to the file system
expecting them to be there
if that server instance goes down so
that means you then have to use an
external
data store to store your files on and of
course you can use
the google cloud storage service if
you're on google cloud
or other options as well depending on
where you are just for files
but then databases are another example
where you don't want to run your
you know back in the lamp stack days we
would run our apache server and our my
sql server on the same
actual server and if that thing went
down or the hard drive was corrupted
you're in big trouble
now we need to take those databases and
i'll also move them out to an external
data store so you could use things like
cloud sql
as one way to externalize those data
stores but that allows you then to have
an elastic application or service tier
that can then talk back to that
that back-end data store yeah
yeah i think it speaks to this idea of
modularization and
ensuring that you're separating compute
and storage so that you can scale both
of those things independently
and run in a very distributed
environment um
okay so we have a lot of serverless
products at
google cloud or the top three that we
always speak about but
lopey2345 asks here please explain the
difference between
app engine and cloud run and which one
we should be using
and this is actually uh one of our more
popular questions we've gotten from
multiple people so
martin why don't you go ahead and take
this one yeah
i think actually over time we have seen
app engine and cloud run becoming more
and more similar because
as we are all learning about you know
cloud native and and we're
cloud providers like google and
developers like you guys we're all
adopting these uh best practices that
james talked about a minute ago
so because app engine and cloud run
adapt
adopt all all those best practices
they're fairly similar i would say and
if i start a new project i think about
what does the team
know does the team know either of these
products then pick that product
if the team knows both or neither i
would
i guess i would use cloud run if i
already have
a container based uh developer workflow
if i like containers
some companies uh do that because in app
engine you don't have containers
in cloud run you can have containers if
you want to but both are
perfectly good choices yeah and is there
a path
from app engine to cloud run if somebody
was interested
yeah you typically in app engine for
example you would write a node
app or a python native app and deploy to
app engine
and you really don't have to really
change anything uh or
i guess a few a few lines at the top of
your file
to move it from app engine to cloud run
so it's it's fairly easy
yeah then one of the the biggest
challenges there is just going to
a container-based docker container based
packaging
method and there is some easy ways to do
that
so there's something called build pla
build packs and we have the google cloud
build packs
and they you can take an existing source
code base
and give it to build packs and it'll
create a container for you if you need
more flexibility or you want to
have more control over the process then
you can use a docker file
as the way to define how your container
gets created
but both of those are now supported by
cloud run so when you do a source based
deployment
with cloud run similar to how you do it
on app engine
uh we will use a docker file if it
exists to create the container or we'll
use build packs to fall back to awesome
so it sounds like there are tools
that people can use if they're
interested in transitioning over one of
the other questions that we get often
about cloud run is does somebody need to
truly understand containers to
use cloud run whatsoever um
martin and james i'm sure you both have
opinions on this
yeah i mean so it used to be that you
had to understand containers you had to
create a docker file uh
so but now you can do gcloud
run deploy source and you just deploy
like your native node app or python app
or
or java app and it's deployed from
source and
under the covers it's all containers on
google site but
you you may or may not see the container
so depending on
if you like containers you can you have
your own docker file and do that stuff
if you don't like containers just deploy
from source but it's all containers over
here
yeah i feel like that's worth restating
um just how easy the experience can be
to build from source for somebody who
may not want to understand containers at
that level i think it just speaks to how
we're continuously creating higher
levels of abstraction for those who do
want to focus specifically on just the
application logic
the nice thing is that containers are
still there and they're underneath the
covers so
you get that portability that containers
gives you where
you can take that same container that
may have been transparently created for
you and run it on kubernetes
run it via docker on your local machine
wherever docker container runs you can
run that container which is nice to have
that portability so yeah it's still
containers underneath the covers but you
don't necessarily need to think about
containers and how they get created
yeah you can reap the same benefits
that's awesome so with the next question
jim h uh this is a little particular but
he wants to share his python
apps apis with his friends using google
cloud run
but he's completely unfamiliar with
containers or how he might package his
python or windows api so he can take
advantage of google cloud run
where does he start similar to i think
what we just talked about james you said
build packs is one option
uh anything else here to add yeah i
think build packs are the really the
transparent way to
go from that python source code to a
container
build packs are a cloud native
foundation under the cloud native
computing foundation
they're called cloud native build packs
so this is an open
standard and google cloud has built our
build packs we have samples on our
github
i think it's just called uh build pack
samples and of course there's a python
sample there
so check that one out uh and you'll
you'll see that with python there is one
little trick that you need to know about
which is
you need to tell the build packs how to
actually start your application and so
there's something called a proc file
is one way to do that and so it that's
one thing that python doesn't give us
for build packs is the ability to know
what application to start in your python
code whereas in node
this is something that you do through an
npm start command uh and other
frameworks have different ways to
for the build packs to know what
commands to start but with python we
don't know how to start your application
so that's the one little thing that
you're going to have to add in
potentially from
versus what you have now um but yeah
check out the buildpack samples for
python that should be pretty helpful to
get you going perfect awesome okay so
next question is from isias
could you explain how to set up cloud
run on anthos
uh james do you want to start sure
yeah so uh what's called cloud run for
anthos is a way to have the cloud run
experience
on anthos which is uh a way to be
multi-cloud be on-prem
with gke our kubernetes engine and so
with cloud run for anthos you get all
the great things about cloud run but you
get them on top
of gke and so you can use this
either in our gke service you could use
it on other cloud providers you could
use it on prem
and to get started you first need to
have anthos and so if you're in the
google cloud console if you actually go
into cloud run
and you go try to deploy an application
which you just say like create service
then you click on anthos as the
deployment target if you don't already
have an anthous cluster set up
then it will actually help you walk
through and create that anthos cluster
there are other ways to create an
anthous cluster on google cloud as well
and once you get an anthous cluster
you can then deploy to it through the
cloud run ui
or through the typical ways that you
deploy to cloud run which is like
command line is one option you do gcloud
run deploy
to deploy your application you can do
that to to deploy to cloud run for
anthony's as well so
but the start with the console uh
console.google.org
console.cloud.google.com and uh and just
go to cloudrun
and pick anthous as the target and uh
should be
pretty straightforward to deploy from
there
cool sounds like there's a couple of
options there to get started uh with
cloud run on for anthos um our next
question is from diraj p who asks do the
environment variables in the cloud run
dashboard allow kms
encrypted values to be specified instead
of publicly exposing database
credentials
uh martin what about you yeah
so yeah so first off the great question
and the background here is
uh i see that the word public is used
here
if you have environment well so it used
to be
for years and years it has been
considered best practice to have
things like database passwords
file paths and things like that as
environment variables so they're not
hard coded in your code
that is a great practice now if you
lately so people have started saying
well actually if i have it in the
environment variables
then if if part of my application maybe
i have a malicious library
somewhere in my application that i
downloaded open source
something it could read environment
variables
so i want to be even more secure than
that
and and that is i think is where this
question comes from so if you have if
you use environment variables in
cloudrun they're not public
it's only you can see them but if but
you could potentially have a piece of
malicious code
inside your application that can read
environment variables and the way to get
around that of course this is of course
a common problem
and so to get around that you use secret
manager which is part of your google
cloud account
you just turn it on and that is a very
secure way of storing these secrets like
database passwords and so on if you want
to do something that's
even more secure than having it just
environment variables and you can
set things up so they audited and all
that good stuff in secret manager
right and just for those who haven't
heard of secret manager it's a secure
and convenient storage system for api
keys
passwords certificates other sensitive
data and it kind of gives you this
central place and source of truth to
manage all of these things and audit
secrets across google cloud
so definitely a great tool to use okay
so next question comes from
george l who asks do you have any tips
on how to accurately estimate costs for
using cloud run in this way
uh james i'm going to you for this one
yeah so um cost estimation with
something that's elastic
can be hard this is like your power
bill your energy bill that you get from
the power company
is how much is the bill going to be next
month i don't know it depends on how
much you use
and so usually the way that we do
estimation
just like you probably do estimation of
what your energy bill is going to be
is you base it on what you did in the
past and so based on
the the past bill that's how you can
determine
likely or the ballpark of your future
bill
so usually the way that we do cost
estimation when you're in
a environment that is scalable like
cloud run
is you do a test with that tries to
simulate
what your actual traffic is going to be
and then you take that test and
you then see all right how much money
did we spend with that test and then you
can extrapolate from there
how much money it's going to be when
you're actually live
there is a cost calculator that you can
use on the google cloud website too
but this is not um exactly going to
be give you a real world picture because
you're going to have to estimate
how many concurrent connections are
going to be coming in which could be
really hard to actually estimate in your
real world usage of
your backend service or your application
so um
so really to if you want to get the the
most accurate number
you need to actually run a simulation
yeah it sounds like a chicken and egg
problem you wanna
you wanna find out but you also need to
test it out first but do you find that
there's a
certain size in this simulation that you
need to run through to experiment and be
able to extrapolate for example
um you know scale up to thousands of
concurrent connections or
is there a certain minimum that you
think that people need to run through
for the simulation
one of the hard things is that there's a
lot of knobs that you can turn to kind
of
change the behavior so with cloud run
the default number of concurrent
connections to a given instance is 80.
you can turn that down to as few as one
or up to as many as 250 concurrent
connections
and this can dramatically impact your
bill but it can also dramatically impact
your performance
so if you turn it all the way up to 250
then that's great that means
you're going to get 250 concurrent
connections to a single instance
and you only get build the cpu and
memory time for
for one instance across those 250
concurrent
connections but if your workloads are
very io and cpu intensive
then you may actually be causing a huge
performance degradation
by doing this which then may send more
requests to
to other instances because they can't
handle those requests potentially as
fast
and so it's really with simulation
testing
you want to try to actually make the
load look as similar to the real world
load
that you're going to have and and then
turn some of those knobs and see
oh if i turn the number of concurrent
connections up or i turn the number of
cpus up or whatever it may be
then it's going to change some things
and so you're going to have to do some
testing to figure out what the optimal
configuration is
it's actually one of the really nice
things about cloud run that you can have
concurrent connections
some of the other serverless platforms
actually don't allow you to have
concurrent connections multiple
concurrent connections
and so then you're actually paying like
per request you're not getting the
advantage of
being able to handle many connections on
a single instance
and only get billed for that one
instance and also right right
and also in my experience the
application real world applications i've
worked on
it's seldom cloud run that that is the
big
dollar item bill it is usually bandwidth
or databases
and and that stuff you're going to have
whether you do serverless or not
and so yeah in my experience most of the
money lands there
you should perhaps look at make sure you
include bandwidth and databases in
when you make estimates yeah important
to be able to isolate the issue during
this testing phase
um okay so our next question is from
vildon
c who asks what if i want to access my
private google cloud storage
from cloud run um martin why don't you
take this one
yeah so i'm not sure what building means
here but
it could be either i want to access a
google cloud storage bucket in gcp
that's private to me
or it could be that maybe uh means
google drive private storage so if it's
a google cloud storage bucket that is
private
to only to only building can see it
what wilden needs to do is to find the
name of that
compute compute engine account that
that run cloud run runs
as and you and then you can find that
in in the cloud console
and then that looks like an email
address and then give access
for that account to this cloud storage
bucket
and then you would read using the cloud
storage api
it's a library you can you can download
and actually
you're referring sorry go ahead yeah and
actually it's the same thing if it's
google drive
we're talking about i've written many
applications that access my private
drive then again i find that compute
engine account it looks like an email
address i share
uh you know a folder in my google drive
or an individual spreadsheet i click
share
paste that uh that in there and give it
read access and now my cloud run
can read that and and the just like with
cloud storage
there is a client library you download
to access drive
oh that's awesome i didn't know that you
could use the same service account for
these external storage locations too
um so yeah we just released a video i
think
is it this week or next week where we
actually have a rest api
running on cloud run and the back end is
a google spreadsheet so you don't have
to muck around with databases it's far
easier to
have yeah spreadsheet as a database and
cloudrun reads from the spreadsheet
yeah that's awesome the first time that
i added a service account to
a google drive doc and all of a sudden
it magically shared i was just blown
away i was like well all these
identities are connected
and it was pretty awesome yeah see even
we still get blown away even if you work
with it a lot every day
um and for those of uh you that are
listening or watching a surface account
is sort of this
special kind of account used by an
application or a virtual machine
as martin was explaining not a person so
applications use service accounts to
make
authorized api calls authorized as
either the service account itself or
as google workspace or cloud identity
users through this domain-wide
delegation
all right so we have another question
here by
dina caron s who says i would like to
see how
role-based authorization can be done uh
james why don't we go to you yeah sure
so
this is back to the service account so
when you have a service account
you uh there's there's actually two
different sides of the service account
in cloud run
there's the the service account that the
service
runs as and then you can also assign
service accounts that can
talk to a service so that's one way that
you can control
who actually has access to call your
cloud run service
so if you want to make it so that only
particular service accounts can call
make a call to a cloud run service
you can do that you can also give
certain people a role called i think
it's called cloud run invoker role
which you can say all right martin you
have the cloud run invoker role for this
service
and that allows you to then call that
service so there's a few different ways
within
iam in google cloud to configure it but
certainly
cloud run services can be locked down to
specific service accounts specific users
specific roles that can make actual http
calls
and if they don't have that then it's
actually google cloud that blocks that
your application doesn't need to have
that logic to do that block
do that role-based uh auth google cloud
just does that for you
and also and and service accounts that's
great for if you have like machines
calling machines and machines calling
um services uh
i know if dinacorn is talking about end
users coming in through a web browser
and hitting services uh then you
probably want to look at
firebase off uh that is one way of
dealing with it you put firebase
off on your service and now people can
sign in with their google account or
facebook account
apple account if there's a bunch of
checkboxes you can turn
them on and off um and you should
also i want to put a bug in your area at
innercorn about
identity aware proxy that is
also a product that can sit in front of
your app engine
apps and when you can for example say
everybody at my company can do this
and only the people in the finance
department can do these
access these few services so there are
there are many things to choose from but
have a look at firebase auth
identity where aware proxy well i'm very
glad you brought that up because
this is a perfect segue into our next
question
who is from neil kaye
and he asks can we expect iap
to support cloud run anytime soon we get
this question a lot so
uh yes definitely this this uh we're
working hard
on it always working hard
um yes and as martin explained uh iap
lets you use identity and context to
guard access to your applications and
vms
so you get this central authorization
layer for any applications that are
accessed by https specifically
then you can use application level
access control models instead of relying
on
network firewalls awesome and also by
the way if neil is writing an api
specifically um and it doesn't want to
use iap
there well there is also the api gateway
that was just made available
that can do sit in front of your cloud
run services
or functions or whatever and do uh
authentication so have a look and see if
i ap
or api gateway is best fit for your app
awesome yeah and we're gonna include
hopefully the links to some of these
uh in the description after this um so
if you want to check out iap and some of
the other things we talked about service
accounts
please go ahead and let's take a look um
okay so our next question is from
senjuvie
who asks does cloud run support
websockets
uh james what about you sure yeah so
this was actually just announced
a couple weeks ago but cloud run now
generally available supports
uh websockets uh i think it's actually
still in beta so maybe not generally
available yet i think those are two
different designations but
but you can do it you deploy a websocket
application today and it should just
work
so there's a few different ways that you
can do this
one is that you can do the http 1.1
upgrade
to a websocket and that works fine you
can also do something
over http 2 and use what's called h2c
which is cleartext http 2 and cloudrun
supports that as the mechanism to
connect from
essentially the load balancer proxy and
your application as well
so a number of different options there
you could also do server send events
is a popular option which does chunked
encoded responses
so that's one way to do it and then of
course with the support
it also brings grpc streaming support
bi-directional grpc streaming support
so your cloud run services can actually
do bi-directional communication on cloud
run
and that i think that actually ends up
using http 2 underneath the covers
usually
but um really great support for
real-time push-based
applications and services yeah well and
because of this
bi-directional ongoing conversation
between client and server and some of
the use cases you just mentioned
do you foresee that this support for
websockets does actually improve
application performance for event driven
architectures
yeah it definitely is important if
you're doing anything event driven
event driven or streaming why this is
important
and why um cloud run is a great fit for
this is that
typically when you have this event
streaming services
you have a lot of idle connections and
so these connections are just sitting
there
waiting for some event to send down to
the client and
with cloud run because you can support
up to that 250 concurrent connections
per instance if a lot of those
connections are just
idle that's okay you're not going to
have to spin up let's say 250 instances
to support 250 concurrent connections
you really could handle that on a single
instance and so that's going to save you
money
so it's just a more efficient way to
utilize those resources so
yeah with event driven architectures the
support for
streaming and push and bidirectional
communication on cloud run is great
yeah yeah absolutely i think this is
really valuable for anyone who doesn't
know that concurrent connections on a
single instance are possible and that
you can use it
to get the most value out of this um
okay so our next question
is from do l who asks hey
a question about cloud run on gke or
cloud run
for anthos versus k native uh
is g cloud run deploy a thin wrapper on
top of cube ctl apply
can i use cube cdl only are there any
features that gcloud run deploy provides
that cube ctl apply
doesn't uh i will go to james yeah
so great question so for those that
aren't aware knativ
is a way that you can make kubernetes
easier
and make it serverless and this is
actually what's underneath cloudrun for
antha so k-native is an open source
project
with the cloud native computing
foundation and because it's based on
kubernetes
the tool to interact with it typically
is coop ctl it's the cube control
lots of different names for it but it's
a way to take a yaml document and give
it to
kubernetes and so when you work with k
native or cloud run for anthos
you give a document to your kubernetes
cluster that describes the services
that you want to have up and running and
so
with cloud run the fully managed version
there
isn't a direct way to do coop ctl apply
of a document
and that's because there isn't a
kubernetes cluster actually
there there is no kubernetes cluster
with the fully managed cloud run
there is one of our co-workers ahmet who
created a clever way to do this
and so it's simulating a kubernetes
cluster but then does
the what's needed underneath the covers
to talk to cloud run fully managed
but there is a way to get yaml documents
out of
cloudrun fully managed so that then if
you are migrating from cloud room fully
managed to cloud run for anthos or
knativ
you can get the yaml document definition
that defines your
cloud run services out and then you can
coop ctl apply those into k native or
cloud run for anthos so there is great
interoperability there between them
but because there isn't actually a
kubernetes cluster
with cloud run fully managed there isn't
a
a direct officially supported way to
apply that document
nice okay thank you so okay at least
through coupes
yeah awesome so okay we have a couple
more that i'm trying to squeeze into
here with the time that we have so
raul g asks is cloud trace also
available
automatically for the cloud run service
uh martin
yes and so yes it has some default stuff
in there
often i hear users want to add more
stuff
so you get some tracking for free some
tracing for free
if you want more tracing you just um
pull in the open telemetry or cloudtrace
libraries and then you can
add more detailed instrumentation and
just so everybody knows this is a really
cool thing cloud trace
you can in cloud trace you can see for
example like
my my slowest uh response times what
happens
inside those is it the database that's
holding up the response or is it
calling to another service and you get
pretty graphs of that and can
troubleshoot and
narrow down where things go wrong
awesome yeah definitely leverage cloud
trace
um okay so the next question the disco
mole
which paints a very interesting picture
in my head
asks can you speed up your cold starts
so
choosing cloud run over aws lambda is
finally a no-brainer
uh martin i'll go to you yeah so
uh there are best practices in the cloud
run documentation for reducing um
startup times and cold start times but
then recently
there is a feature that i use on every
single cloud run service i deploy now
nowadays when even if i'm really
concerned about cold starts and that is
a new feature called min instances so
when you deploy your cloud run service
you can say
i want they're always i don't want you
to scale down to zero so there will be a
cold start
i always want there to be at least one
server ready with my service loaded on
it so
that way you get way fewer cold starts
min instances and you could set that to
be whatever so it doesn't have to be one
you
if you want there to be a hundred
instances just waiting for requests that
you could set it to 100
you would of course pay a little bit
more money um but uh but certainly an
option to set that to avoid cold starts
yeah and there are a couple other things
you can do in terms of
initialization of the container on cloud
run right so like for example
creating a linear service reducing
module loading that happens if you're on
uh node.js or python shortening your
initializations in general
um anything else to add in terms of that
yeah yeah there's a good rundown in the
in the docks for cloud run
uh about those things they call out what
you described here stephanie a few other
things
i'll point out in the world of java
that's the world that i'm in java kotlin
and scala
there's a a kind of newer tool called
gravium native image
that allows you to take jvm-based
applications and ahead of time compile
them
and i was able to take an application
that would take like five seconds to
start and
withdraw vm native image i was able to
make it start in like a hundred
milliseconds
and so if you're in the world of jvm
check out grovium native image it's
pretty awesome for
serverless and and uh avoiding cold
starts
sweet cool check that out um okay so i
think this is our final question that we
have time
for today which is from manpreet s who
asks
it would be nice if we could automate
processes in workflows
uh i think he wants that to be addressed
so
uh martin how about you first yeah so i
don't know exactly
what manpreet is asking for what it
means by automating workflows
there is a product that just became
available called workflows
and it works great with uh serverless or
server full applications
what we've seen when we started using
workflow ourselves
is that a lot of the code that we would
write you know um
uh in in code like do this call this
thing
wait if that happens you can now write
declaratively
in yaml or in json which is far safer
so all those if statements and all that
stuff is sort of declarative
in a file that then uh deals with the
basically translating a flowchart into
calling services in a certain order and
branching and so on
uh workflows check that out yeah that
just came out and
is it in beta or ga now i think mipga i
think so yeah
yeah awesome yeah i mean that's for
chaining together apis and it would be
great to
be used in conjunction with cloud run
and cloud functions for example or
anything that has an api
um great um james you have anything else
to add here
no uh yeah thanks for asking us great
questions and hopefully we get to do
more of these
yeah sweet thank you so much martin and
james for being on y'all provided
the most insight on this and i think
this was a very very valuable and
popular topic for people
okay thank you everyone else who's
watching for joining our very first ask
google cloud live chat
we hope your questions got answered but
if not we'll be
back with more live chats throughout the
year we'll be featuring
your questions from youtube instagram
and twitter so
send in your questions using the hashtag
askgooglecloud
and comment below if you have a question
that we didn't get to today
thank you so much for watching and we'll
see you all next time
you